[Music]
in everything made in China news this
was submitted by NASA likely Chinese
scholars are claiming that European
languages are actually just Mandarin
dialects I know they're turning into the
new Koreans so it's basically like what
do they call it like whitewashing things
now they're just trying to yellow wash
things he can make that joke
I cannot yes you can maybe you could do
it okay can we trade you can make that
joke mmm that's different right
cuz the past but he also never asked for
it so I feel like if he did slip aside
but then again he said something about
some black [ __ ] one time he called
flack for that so and that's the first
thing from like then we're black [ __ ]
and there's two different blocks what
was they being [ __ ] though I mean
sometimes that's it that's what I would
ask are they being [ __ ] oh yeah
because the black waters evident they
are black and then sometimes black women
do AG like [ __ ] not all not all yeah
[ __ ] actually dudes act more like
[ __ ] than a lot of females those be
gossiping like [ __ ] yeah I don't like
that [ __ ] man I [ __ ] be gossiping
like [ __ ] be gossiping yeah yeah but
[ __ ] is never gossiping my dudes if
you notice that what have [ __ ] never
gossip like dudes no no now they can
have multiple conversations yeah
multiple gossips going on at once
I'll see you're saying the word [ __ ] is
just [ __ ] if enough oh yeah
[Laughter]
pass away like I I'm light-skinned I
mean you know I just I'll trade with
someone else
hey man there will be a ceremony I will
be given the past someone else I'll be
there will be a ceremony living in LA
may hope it's an L yeah they're probably
gonna kill you right after no don't be
super cool about it super cool so they
the world civilization Research
Association scholars I was made up as
[ __ ] dude I'm claiming that Western
civilization originates from China and
that all European language our languages
are only Mandarin dialects mmm in your
face you're up so for example yellow
resembles the Mandarin word for it low
leaf falling which is which is what how
do you pronounce it Oh leaf is yeah yeah
I don't know how falling is what it's
written here ye Lu oh yeah no okay yes
will say yeah ro that's what I'm saying
you see yo this one in here you can read
that I could read that Oh Lord yeah yeah
yeah so come on okay so hold on so then
that means but it's like in um like old
Chinese like old all the English is not
like die oh it's like that it's like
older and they're all the same
one says yellow anymore it's because um
because it is the colour of autumn while
hearts resembles the core which is head
head dead head back the city listen I
stopped taking my Mandarin classes so I
can't read oh hi yeah they don't tell me
the cone they're just finding
similarities in the language and they're
like yeah that sounds like that yeah
and these are [ __ ] scholars so we're
just gonna act like Egypt didn't exist
what language is that what so that what
they're saying here is that so
apparently they are claiming that due to
the fact that there is no history in
Europe before the 15th century compared
to China they made up a fabricated
stories about ancient Egyptian great
Roman civilizations which is all based
on Chinese history according to them so
wait so they made up stories about Egypt
even though these pyramids exist so you
know how you you know the pyramids exist
it's an Asian thing so ages may period
this is very common thinking actually
yeah exactly so they're not crazy
Bart and Joe have this thing where
they're like oh yeah that's an Asian
thing so oh yeah parents yelling at
their kids to be don't that's an Asian
thing what their kids here good grades
this nation but it's like everyone does
that [ __ ] like I got y'all that
forgetting [ __ ] your clothes smell like
mothballs
that's the agent thing agent I don't
know dude that's a white thing my mom
use that or cedar wood that's a guy
thing a dirty guy thing no no no I've
never ever delos balls not me either I'm
good at it cuz the agents are scared of
mocs I have a family member who smells
who smells dusty dusty that's the thing
the smell don't say I know that smell oh
you showed us you kept your [ __ ] in the
closet for a really long time and like
maybe you wore it once and you just put
it right back if your smells like a
Salvation Army yes
yeah you're going to go it's like a
heavy been sitting there for a while
1975 like it's just like old records
yeah yeah you pass them before though
Oh like a hippie G oh you didn't have to
have my back there but you did I won't I
won't forget it a woman had just drawn I
was being a hotshot thank you she's a
woman she had your back he's like I'm
just as shocked as you are
please don't come after me cancel
culture please what's the opposite of
cancel culture enter if you're already
zit the little belt like enter really
hurts the channel enter culture cancel
culture but I like subscribe photos the
world civilization Research Association
of God these Schmucks
I met they're not all days at all wait
they're all lazy oh my god Chinese
scholars dude they're scholars I would
hate to have an argument with these guys
stupidest scholars I just provided
everything with as an Asian thing
I'm like well how do you cook crack
because I know and I'm pretty sure
there's not an age of things I show you
man come on just come on with the purity
pledge easy in the background why they
do Frank Lucas they get it from over
there what wait what that was a kid from
Singapore someone somewhere like that
heroin heroin is Southeast Asia
yes are not Singapore but like yeah
Thailand all all in that area yeah did
you know I heard that Italians didn't
have tomatoes and Italy yeah yeah for a
long time yep
they had like white pizzas up until like
the 1400s are you from South America
talk about moving in on the market and
rebranding the [ __ ] out of it I think
the Italians did the best job ever
I had pizza in Italy dough have you you
might have low quality taste buds and
you don't even know it you think this
can be eating you think this koala t
know this is commitment this is knowing
exactly how much money there's no this
is knowing how much money is gonna take
the substitute my drink for shape this
is this is what commitment looks like so
yet I have good taste buds
i order travel to go eat I don't give a
care about the loo or Eiffel Tower know
what these crepes hit long around this
Eiffel Tower so yes I have what's your
favorite pizza then deep-dish you go to
Italy they're gonna put a teaspoon of
[ __ ] tomatoes paste on your pizza and
then it's just like a dollop of ricotta
like POW like right there everything
I'll sprinkle some green parsley and
some tin over like oh there's an
appeaser I'm like little guy
so you just knows bro if I want to New
York Pizza
I'm with it's the best tomato sauce you
ever had didn't cover the [ __ ] thing
in it exactly ruins the taste of it are
you hearing what you're saying [ __ ] what
seems like a condom he could be in my
corner this is my dude right here he has
really bad quality taste buds that's not
true I actually just did a water taste
test with Nicki and I [ __ ] won it
tastes like mud right the Sonia sweet it
literally tastes like Pepsi sweat yeah
so like doing water you want to go feed
you know you want to go alkaline that's
just my this is my opinion it's my
waters pretty [ __ ] good that's my
favorite one I do I do a B on if I have
to it's not my first choice and yeah
sucks dude it tastes dirty it's pretty
gross that's me that is not as dirty as
like Aquafina the Ithaca low quality
taste but the funnies like one of the
worst - I like the Sami actually no I
only disagree with him about yeah it's a
butterfly yeah it's nothing I ate you
low Hawaiian waters good what's what was
that it just comes in a bottle like a
hole Oh were you over in Hawaii yeah
yeah coming out of the tap is pretty
good over there
oh is it pretty good well maybe you get
a little drop of it then because it's so
good you know you just want a little
drop it's not a tomato Steve no but
that's how you really enjoy something
right you don't want to overwhelm
yourself mm-hmm it's so they do make
good wine and they have good cheese but
they don't put the good cheese on the
pizza so I don't understand absolutely a
bit an Asian thing
I'm max trigger now
[Music]